let's go so her dad was in the edl
now he accepts her as a muslim
sadly my father he became very involved
with them
and he actually stopped speaking to me
so amara's dad invited her out to eat
and took her out for a beautiful turkish
night
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products the website is in
the description link below
you can also use the discount code
salaam 10
for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum better character
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah welcome
to
um this set now this different set you
don't see this guy's couch anymore
because he's left this couch he's
abandoned this couch he's not i will be
back
he's left that jahiri left behind so
what we're doing brother sisters today
is we're reacting reacting in public
it's nice
got the sun here inshallah and we've got
a beautiful
news should i say from a sister who
hasn't spoken to her father who was a
member of the edl and a party you're
very familiar with
i've had interactions with cause
relations with patients with
let's watch inshallah here we go so this
sister's name is amira omaro
yes amira okay let's go so her dad
was in the edl now he accepts her as a
muslim
amira or myra a river from england
shared the heartwarming story
about her reunion with her dad on
instagram
after not seeing him for five years the
edl is the english defense league
which is a group in the uk who are
against islam and against muslims living
here in the uk
sadly my father he became very involved
with them
um and he actually stopped speaking to
me and
you know which was devastating for me
because we'd always had a very very
close relationship
so despite her father adopting
anti-muslim views
amira never gave up on him five years
had gone by um i had tried to call him
tried to email him tried to
um keep in contact with him but it was
almost impossible
um until 2021 this year
i received a message from my father
saying that he wanted to see me and meet
with me
and that he had changed his views
regarding islam and that he no longer is
with the edl
so amara's dad invited her out to eat
and took her out for a beautiful turkish
by the way amara shared a photo of them
at the reunion
it was very emotional to see my father
again after so long
and he was very happy to see me
and he realizes that he had taken a bad
path
and that a lot of the views he had about
islam
was not true and it was just very nice
for me because i know there's a lot of
other rebirths that sometimes feel like
their family will never accept them so
what i would say to you is that
never lose hope if my father can change
his heart than
anyone wow
that is what a way to end that's
absolutely beautiful you know why
because the thing is i can
resonate with that and it's close to
home with me as well and a lot of reverb
people that are watching this you know
and you think to yourself sometimes how
do i deal with it
and me personally sometimes i'm sure she
can relate with this as well maybe
is that i'm basically i might have an
interview with a trainer trying to
arrange inshallah
but the thing is sometimes you do feel
hopeless sometimes you see a
grow a glimpse of hope but sometimes
that
is overshadowed by a conflict that
happens
so these are things with its ups and
downs even with my own father sometimes
i see a glimpse of hope and i'm like
yes and then something happens and it's
like wow now this
he's never gonna he's never going to
accept islam
except me yeah okay but except in islam
never so the thing is i think that's a
brilliant start and it shows
yes his father on his deathbed 20 plus
years
so what that shows brothers and sisters
is firstly if you ever doubt yourself
or doubt the efforts that you're doing
to give dawah to your family members if
you ever feel like you know what
my dad was not working never ever doubt
who your lord is oh
and this is very important no it's true
because there's a lot of stuff like for
example i would talk about my struggles
with not waking up for fajr
any time allah is not limited exactly so
i think what this shows is
allah breaks down things slowly like i
was telling you like recently like my
dad you know
um even like personal things for example
sending my daughter to an islamic school
he's not fond of that i'm trying to say
yeah because of certain reasons and
whatever it may be but the thing is like
i was telling you and he was talking
about a couple of months ago
and i was like oh my my dad's really
making it hard you know he doesn't want
my daughters to go to islamic school
probably two weeks ago my dad picked her
up from the very islamic school you get
it and
remember how much i was telling you how
much that got to me you know at the end
of the day
but the thing is it's that you see allah
changes people's hearts slowly
and we see that with like the sahaba in
it yeah i mean the
good things come to those who wait yeah
they come to
to those who wait yeah and this world is
a test for us
and allah doesn't burden a person more
than they can bear
yeah and look guys just like we wait for
the
the ripest of fruits it takes time you
know dishes when we make them they take
time yeah so with these things it tastes
better yeah you
you're gonna appreciate it more like
she's so happy to meet her father but a
lot of people that have their fathers
don't appreciate their fathers
who knows how much that relationship
would flourish now
and how amazing it is actually it
reminds me of um
instances like ibrahim alaihi salaam and
his father
azer yeah but but you see other
i do the i idolater and idolatra
and you've got ibrahim allah
yeah so and the prophet saw went to that
place and
they stoned him and allah sent the
angels
of the mountains that you know they are
at your disposal
um if you want allah can tell us
if you want you know allah has commanded
us we will crush these mountains but
prophet sallallahu alaihi
said yeah yeah it was mercy he said and
that's what he kept one of his dua
that all the prophets that used he
didn't he saved it for his ummah
and it just shows your brother and
sisters that you never know as reverse
we need to understand that you might be
the ambassador for your family to come
to islam
gradually you might see is impossible
but gradually one day you would see that
happening and as an ambassador you need
to be a good role model
with you adapt the way you carry
yourself because your actions is down
and one thing that i would say is not to
give up ever and to make dua and maybe
your dad had to go through that
and see that for him to get closer
to islam in a way for even accepting you
and islam and changing his views and
this shows you the importance of tawa
god knows whose videos he may have
watched
that may have inspired him before you
know what hold on a second actually this
is all bogus
and i think that's any laws worth i
think what's very important to
understand is
past the age of 25 yeah yeah you're
really set in your ways
it's very difficult for a person to
change habits yeah and psychologists say
there's two main things that will change
a person's habits one is trauma
and the other is constant affirmations
and constantly repetition
so that's something to understand and
that a lot of
investment has gone into maligning islam
yeah and that's entered the subconscious
the unconscious mind of a lot of people
and that's going to take time
that's going to take time for you to do
exactly and we have to be practical
and with our parents they don't like to
be lectured so
islam is pure as long as you are
practicing islam and showing them the
beauty of islam eventually just like a
rock
yeah and a drop of water drops on it
it's not going to break it straight away
but eventually if it's consistent and
persistent eventually a hole will form
and that rock will crack inshallah and
they will accept islam brothers and
sisters
if you enjoyed this if you would like to
see more videos reaction videos out in
the public
comment in the section below and
inshallah we make two
reunites this sister with her father in
jannah he accepts inshallah islam
and for all of us reverse inshallah we
know how painful it can be to think that
they may die on disbelief
till next time
foreign